[موسيقى]
لا يزال من الإبحار ولكن
كل شيء يأتي من أسفل إلى
كان هذا ميتا من أعلى إلى أسفل
صعب جدا
[موسيقى]
الأثاث ليس كل شيء يعتقد
للتعليق على السقف ولكن
نقف على الأرض لذلك اضطررنا إلى ذلك
قاموا مرة واحدة بالبناء المسبق في الشركة و
عزز البناء بالغراء
خشبية أننا حتى إلى
يمكنهم لصق السقف ثم فعلوا
لصقها وثملها في السقف بالرغم من ذلك
لا يمكنك حتى تخيل ذلك
كيف تبدو أصلية لذلك كان لا بد من ذلك
نلتقط الكثير من الصور مرة أخرى
يستدير سواء الزخرفة سواء كل ذلك
ثم حصلنا على المنزل
منحدرين إلى جانب واحد 6 درجات
الميل للجانب الآخر 4 درجات
نريد الدماغ قليلا
لعب مقالب ولدينا واحدة
يلاحق الرجل نافذة الصورة الكبيرة
في الاعلى
وأنت تقف على السقف المعوج
لكن انظر من النافذة إلى الأشجار
كل شيء خارج المنزل هو السياج نعم
مستقيم ومعوج في المنزل وذاك
يبدأ الدماغ بالدوران ولا يعرف
ما هو الآن ما هو مستقيم و
ثم عليك أن تبدأ مثل هذا
عض الركبتين المهتزة لأن الدماغ
لا بد لي من فرز نفسي أولا
تجد وأن هناك نريد واحدًا
تقدم القليل من الكمامة للناس
وأعتقد أنه يعمل بشكل جيد
أنت تعلم أن هذا ما يدور في رأسك و
هذا خطأ موجود ولكنه موجود
لا تزال ملتوية بعض الشيء و
إنه شيء غريب ومضحك
أشعر وأنا هناك مع ابني
وبالطبع يعتقد ذلك أيضًا
مضحك ومجنون فقط شمال شرق
[موسيقى]
تجربة خاصة إذا قمت بذلك
في الواقع حتى لا يعرف المنزل يميل
يمتد في اتجاهين من هناك
صعب حقًا لأنه سهل
يصاب بالدوار ولكنه شديد
مثيرة للاهتمام ومضحكة حقًا يمكنك ذلك
يلتقط الكثير من الصور
احصل على حمام المنزل تاتش الآن
[موسيقى]
لذلك لدي الكثير من المنازل
رأيت Instagram وبالطبع فعلت
أيضًا عبر Google لأن لدي الكثير جدًا
وجدت مثيرة للاهتمام ولدي
اكتشف أن هذا المنزل موجود
هنا وكان ذلك مثيرًا للاهتمام بسبب ذلك
جئت إلى هنا أيضًا
[موسيقى]